good morning and thank you for joining
us this morning to my left is the acting
Commissioner of U.S Customs and Border
Protection Troy Miller Ricardo ziniga to
my right from the United States
Department of State
as you know
on Thursday tomorrow May 11th at 11 59
PM eastern time the title 42 Public
Health order will terminate at that
point we will once again process people
at our Southern border using our
immigration enforcement authorities
under Title VII of the United States
code
our overall approach is to build lawful
Pathways for people to come to the
United States and to impose tougher
consequences on those who choose not to
use those pathways we are taking this
approach within the constraints of a
broken immigration system that Congress
has not fixed for more than two decades
and without the resources we need
Personnel facilities transportation and
others that we have requested of
Congress and that we were not given
we have seen the effectiveness of our
approach more than 100 000 people from
Cuba Haiti Nicaragua and Venezuela have
arrived lawfully through the pathway we
have made available to them and we
reduce border encounters from these
groups by 90 percent between December of
last year and March of this year
our president has led the largest
expansion of lawful Pathways ever
at the same time we are clear-eyed about
the challenges we are likely to face in
the days and weeks ahead which have the
potential to be very difficult
even after nearly two years of
preparation we expect to see large
numbers of encounters at our Southern
Border in the days and weeks after May
11th we are already seeing High numbers
of Encounters in certain sectors
this places an incredible strain on our
Personnel our facilities and our
communities with whom we partner closely
our plan will deliver results that it
will take time for those results to be
fully realized and it is essential that
we all take this into account
I cannot over emphasize that our current
situation is the outcome of Congress
leaving a broken outdated immigration
system in place for over two decades
despite unanimous agreement that we
desperately need legislative reform
it is also the result of congress's
decision not to provide us with the
resources we need and that we requested
are of the Everest within the
constraints of our broken immigration
system are focused on ensuring that the
process is safe orderly and Humane all
while protecting our dedicated Workforce
and our communities
let me be clear
the lifting of the title 42 Public
Health order does not mean our border is
open in fact it is the contrary our use
of our immigration enforcement
authorities under title 8 of the United
States code means tougher consequences
for people who cross the border
illegally
unlike under title 42 an individual who
is removed under title eight is subject
to at least a five-year bar on re-entry
into the United States and can face
criminal prosecution if they attempt to
cross again
Smugglers have long been hard at work
spreading false information that the
Border will be open after May 11th
it will not be they are lying
to people
who are thinking of making a journey to
our Southern border know this
the Smugglers care only about profit not
people they do not care about you or
your well-being
do not believe their lies do not risk
your life
and your life savings only to be removed
from the United States if if and when
you arrive here
today we are beginning a new digital
advertising campaign in Central and
South America to counter the lives of
the Smugglers with accurate information
about U.S immigration laws this campaign
adds to our extensive ongoing
Communications efforts in the region
as you can see by the images before us
of removal flights and encounters with
our border patrol agents we are making
it very clear that our border is not
open that Crossing irregularly is
against the law and that those who are
not eligible for Relief will be quickly
returned
do not listen to the lies of the
Smugglers this is what will happen to
you
you will be returned
today alongside the Department of
Justice we are finalizing a new rule to
encourage individuals to use available
lawful safe and orderly Pathways to
enter the United States
the rule presumes that those who do not
use lawful Pathways to enter the United
States are ineligible for Asylum it
allows the United States it allows us to
remove individuals who do not establish
a reasonable fear of persecution in the
country of removal
non-citizens can rebut this presumption
only in very limited circumstances for
example
if they have used our lawful Pathways or
sought Asylum or protection in another
country through which they have traveled
and were denied
this rule goes into effect once the
title 42 Public Health order terminates
tomorrow on Thursday at 11 59 PM Eastern
Time
what I have just described are only a
few elements of an expansive effort that
began in 2021 to prepare for this
transition from the title 42 public
health authority to our tougher
immigration enforcement authorities
in addition to obtaining the first
increase in Border Patrol agent hiring
in over a decade the first in over a
decade we are in the process of surging
Personnel to the Border including more
than 1 400 DHS Personnel one thousand
processing coordinators and an
additional one thousand five hundred
Department of Defense personnel
all of these individuals will allow our
Law Enforcement Officers to stay in the
field and focus on their critical
mission
we are delivering on tougher
consequences for unlawful entry
including the return removal and
expulsion of more than 665
000 people during the first half of this
fiscal year we are conducting dozens of
removal flights per week and we continue
to increase our removal flight
capability
we are increasing our efficiency and
reducing processing times at the border
we launched the cdp-1 app which in its
four first four months helped 83 000
individuals schedule an appointment at a
port of entry and we are taking steps to
expand available appointments
we bolstered the capacity of local
governments and ngos just last week we
announced the distribution of an
additional 332 million dollars to
support communities along the southern
border and in the interior of our
country
we are leading an unprecedented law
enforcement disruption campaign that has
led to the arrest of nearly ten thousand
Smugglers who profit from vulnerable
immigrants
knowing that this is a regional
challenge that requires a regional
solution we continue to work with
countries throughout the Americas to
deter irregular migration this includes
a coordinated campaign with Colombia and
Panama to prevent individuals from
following ruthless Smugglers into the
very dangerous area
and we are working with our partners in
Mexico regularly on a range of issues
we are a nation of immigrants
we are also a nation of laws
our immigration laws today are outdated
the solution we are implementing are the
best available within our current legal
Authority but they are short-term
solutions to a decades-old problem
the kind of migration we continue to see
today requires more resources resources
we have requested and have not received
clearer Authority and modernized
processes that only Congress can deliver
we urge it to do so
now I think we'll take some questions
thank you questions
um
Terry uh we've just seen some images
from Texas showing that Texas National
Guard and DPS physically blocking
migrants from uh climbing up the
Riverbanks and accessing U.S oil does
the department believe that that's a
legal enforcement posture by the state
of Texas
uh Nick I'm going to leave it to the our
department of justice to to speak to the
lawfulness or lack thereof of those
actions I will tell you this uh that our
border patrol agents and our officers
work very closely with the Department of
Public Safety in Texas on the ground
when it is a coordinated and
collaborative effort it is essential
that law enforcement work as one team to
address the challenge of the Southern
border
uh thank you Mr secretary how many
incredible fear screening interviews do
you expect to conduct on a daily basis
and are you confident that we'll keep up
with the number of apprehensions you all
are seeing and expect to see in the days
ahead so we are the Department of
Homeland Security with one of our
agencies U.S citizenship and Immigration
Services is indeed surging Asylum
officers to border patrol facilities as
well as to Immigration and Customs
Enforcement detention facilities to
conduct an unprecedented number of
credible fear screenings under the
Asylum rule that is going to be
implemented beginning upon the end of
title 42. we are surging approximately
one thousand uh or more Asylum officers
for that purpose it is very important to
note
that the Asylum rule will take effect if
individuals do not access their lawful
Pathways the pathways that we have made
available to them they will face a
rebuttable presumption but a presumption
of ineligibility for Asylum they will
have to meet a higher bar this president
or president
has led the expansion of lawful Pathways
more than anyone else in our history
with a permit to stay in the country for
a year I wonder how that process is
being done and how secure you are of
those all those veterans that are taking
place
so uh U.S Customs and Border Protection
screens and vets individuals whom we
encounter
individuals the vast majority of
individuals will be returned those who
do not qualify from border patrol
stations or Immigration and Customs
Enforcement detention facilities
uh we often as has every Administration
release individuals into immigration
enforcement proceedings and those
individuals if they do not qualify for
Relief will be removed we screen and vet
individuals whom we encounter Michelle
immigration
um just to follow up on the
of migrants you think will be receiving
those screenings is almost half some and
can you also speak to the agreement with
Mexico I know you guys have specifically
said they're planning to take back
people from the four nationalities for
Cuban Venezuelans nicaraguans and
Haitians but is there a possibility that
they would take back any other
nationalities as well uh Michelle
um
let me let me uh break it down a little
bit uh we are giving
the option to individuals who are in our
custody the option of voluntarily
returning to the country from which they
uh came because of the consequence
of a removal
people have to understand that under
title eight of the United States code
when one is removed one faces eighth at
least a five-year bar to re-entry and so
we will give people an opportunity to
avoid that tougher consequence by
voluntarily returning
if they do not take that option
and they do not claim fear they will be
removed immediately
if they do claim fear they will
encounter a higher threshold under our
Asylum rule unless they have accessed
our lawful Pathways or sought relief in
another country and been denied we are
surging as I mentioned Michelle Asylum
officers to ensure that that screening
process that credible fear screening
process is done fairly
with access to council but expeditiously
how do Americans gain from the
immigration path to our opening sir I
mean nobody ever asked this question do
Americans gain from all the immigrants
they're bringing into the country
different wages they push a price
sir we are a nation of immigrants and we
are a nation of laws individuals who
qualify for Relief under our laws have a
basis to remain in the United States the
contributions of immigrants to this
country is quite clear thank you next
good morning
can you guys anticipate um requesting
supplement funding for the border from
Congress lost I heard there hadn't been
a request made if you do anticipate it
like what type of criteria would would
you know trigger that kind of request
from you guys in December
um of this past year
we sought more than four billion dollars
in funding to address our resource needs
because we are operating within an
entirely broken immigration system and
that is something about which there is
unanimity we did not receive the funding
that we requested we received
approximately half of what we requested
and half of what we needed which is why
we are encountering some of the
challenges we have sought
a reprogramming and we have communicated
to Congress that that reprogramming is a
fraction of what we ultimately need we
have time for time for a Rob
okay
from NBC News uh you mentioned some of
the immigration proceedings the federal
uh are you prepared to start releasing
migrants into the U.S without court
dates and without a way to attract them
to reduce overcrowding so uh when like
other administrations when we release
individuals
we release them on conditions
and their compliance with those
conditions is absolutely necessary and
if they fail to comply we will seek to
apprehend them and remove them they are
ultimately in Immigration enforcement
proceedings but what we are speaking of
what you are inquiring of is a my a
minor is a fraction of the people that
we encounter in fact the vast majority
will be addressed in our border patrol
facilities and our ice Detention
Facility is that not a message so that
the border is open then tomorrow oh
absolutely absolutely not and I think
you can ask the approximately 1.4
million people who were expelled
returned or removed from the United
States this past year do you still
consider this Challenge and not a crisis
I'm sorry if you wanted to add anything
else on Regional processing centers if
not we'll we'll close remarks
um let me just uh um answer Marsha's uh
question uh if I may with respect to
Regional uh processing centers they are
a powerful example of what I expressed
earlier which is that our president has
led the expansion of lawful Pathways
more than anyone preceding him the
regional processing centers are an
extraordinary example of that leadership
these are places where we we feel on a
humanitarian as well as the security
imperative to meet people where they are
to cut the Smugglers out and to provide
them with a safe and orderly way to
arrive in the United States if they
qualify for Relief we are surging our
Personnel in close partnership with the
Department of State in close partnership
with countries in the region
we require a regional response to what
is a regional challenge we will in these
Regional processing centers screen uh
individuals uh to determine whether they
are eligible for Refugee uh status in
the United States whether they qualify
for what we are expanding in our family
reunification programs or whether on an
individualized basis on a case-by-case
basis as the law requires whether they
are eligible for other humanitarian
relief that is what we are doing the the
phenomenon of migration is different
than it was 10 12 years ago we are
seeing an unprecedented level of
migration throughout the hemisphere I
believe there are approximately 20
million displaced people in our
hemisphere
in addition the Smugglers control the
migratory paths we will cut the
Smugglers out we will reach qualifying
individuals where they are and provide
them with a safe and orderly pathway if
they arrive at our Southern border they
will meet consequences we urge migrants
once again not to believe the Smugglers
who are lying to them
solely to make a profit we are building
lawful Pathways for you to come to the
United States do not place your life and
your life savings in the hands of
Ruthless organizations thank you very
much it's a challenge or a crisis